hi there today we're looking at pruning
neural networks without any data by
iteratively conserving synaptic flow by
hidden aura Tanaka
Daniel Coonan Daniel LK yemen's and
Surya Ganguly so this paper on a high
level does what the lottery ticket
hypothesis does but does so without any
date I prunes a neural network at the
beginning and it does so it's able to do
that because it claims that its
algorithm avoids this problem called
layer collapse and then is based on
conserving a quantity they called the
complete synaptic flow and we're going
to look at this and it's pretty cool
algorithm it seems to work pretty well
as always if you want to help out you
can share this video and let me know in
the comments what you think of it I do
read the comments and I would love to
hear from you alright
let's dive in so they're saying pruning
the parameters of deep neural networks
has generated intense interest due to
potential savings in time memory and
energy both during training and at test
time recent works have identified
through an expensive sequence of
training and pruning cycles the
existence of winning lottery tickets or
sparse trainable sub networks at
initialization so what is this paper
talking about if you if you don't know
much about pruning here is kind of a
basic overview so if you have a neural
network that's consists of many many
layers of neurons what you can do that
one way of pruning that what what the
goal is is to end up with a small neural
network that performs well but for now
we have a big neural network that
doesn't perform well it hasn't been
trained yet right so what you can do is
you can first train the neural network
and then you have a big neural network
that performs well and then you can
prune it now a lot of times a lot of the
time this this has been seen as sort of
the pruning way you would train the big
neural networking
then you would prune it because the
other way was not feasible first pruning
and then training was not feasible you
might you might ask okay we might just
want to start with a small one and yeah
that's correct so what does this first
way buy you this first way is buys you
mainly two things so imagine this
network right here is much smaller than
the original network so it is less it
uses less storage so you can potentially
if you want to shape it to like a
customer over the Internet you maybe
instead of a gigabyte you only have to
transfer a few megabytes and that's
pretty cool the second thing if you
prune in the correct way you can also
make it faster because now there's less
weights to multiply with you can
actually make it go faster so pruning is
a now this this combines with techniques
called distillation and so on is our
ways to make the networks smaller and
faster so if your customers are for
example on non mobile phones
then you can ship you can train a big
network to a good performance on your
big GPU server and then ship it out to a
mobile phone once it's small and it will
perform fairly well on that mobile phone
without GPU so what about this other way
now in order to do the other way we
would sort of have to have an idea which
one of these big networks which sub
parts of these layers are the good ones
right in order for us to do this first
prune and then train the interesting
thing is that the paper the lottery
ticket hypothesis I've done a video on
this and we've also interviewed the
author on our ml Street Talk podcast
this paper has shown that this is in
fact possible a long time people have
thought we need the big network in order
to Train right we'd so sort of the
bigness of the network the full
connectedness of the network is required
for the training dynamics but this paper
is shown there's not possible you can
prune at the very beginning now what
they do it first terrains in your
network like in the olden days then it
prunes the neural network and then it
remembers which connections of the
terrain neural network it has pruned and
then it simply goes back to the
beginning of training right here up here
and says I now know which connections
are important and I'm simply going to
prune all the other connections other
than these ones and then interestingly
if you prune first and then train that
works just as well and can actually work
even better the interesting thing here
is that I mean this is a big big cycle
but the interesting thing that the paper
demonstrates is that this is even
possible right people thought it wasn't
possible and this paper demonstrates if
you only knew if you only knew which
ones you must retain you can prune at
the beginning of training the lottery
ticket that poultice is paper though
still requires to actually train the
full network and then do the pruning
like in a classic way in order to find
out which ones you need to prune and
which ones you don't this paper right
here takes that idea and says can we
find can we find a pruning algorithm
that prunes at the beginning of training
yet does not have to train the full
network in fact doesn't look at any of
the data ok and this is are going to be
our starting point so their story is
going to be it's quite an involved story
and I think the overview is important
well as we go through the paper so first
they name this problem called layer
collapse now layer collapse is going to
be whenever a pruning algorithm removes
the entirety of a neural network layer
which means that no information can flow
anymore and therefore the network can't
drain and they claim that this is the
main problem why these current pruning
algorithms cannot achieve very high
pruning ratios so can it look very high
compression
shows is because they do premature layer
collapse they then formulate this
maximal critical critical compression
axiom that has sort of a guiding
principle to build pruning algorithms
second they show that this quantity
called synaptic salience II a general
class of gradient based scores for
pruning is conserved at every hidden
unit layer of a neural network so they
show that these are conserved and they
show this because this is their their
argument is going to be first the
argument is layer collapse is a problem
the second argument is these things are
conserved in these the conservation of
the synaptic saliency leads to the layer
collapse and we're going to see how that
happens and then third they say the
solution to that is iterative pruning so
they show this at the at the example of
iterative magnitude pruning which we
know avoids layer collapse so iterative
magnitude pruning is something that
happens in this lottery ticket way of of
doing it this lottery ticket way you can
actually do it not in one step but it
tends to work better when you want to go
from one hundred percent of your weights
to just 5% of your weights it tends to
work better if you do it in stages so
first you go to 90 percent to 80 to 70
and so on down to your desired thing and
this iterative procedure they claim is
what is what circumvents this problem of
layer collapse and then at last they say
we prove that a pruning algorithm yeah
avoids layer collapse entirely and
satisfies blah blah blah if it uses
iterative positive synaptic salient
z-scores so they bring it all together
and say if an algorithm satisfies our
axiom and if the algorithm is an
algorithm that uses these salience is
like this one here and if the algorithm
is iterative then it is not going to be
subject to layer collapse and therefore
it is going to be able to compress to a
very high compression ratio and then
they actually do suggest an algorithm
this synaptic sorry iterative synaptic
flow pruning syn flow that does all of
this and never looks at any data all
right this is quite a story but remember
what we're doing first layer collapses a
problem second why is layer collapse a
problem it's because of this synaptic
saliency conservation third we can avoid
it by doing iterative pruning and lastly
this algorithm does it without looking
at data okay so layer layer collapse
layer collapse is a pretty simple
phenomenon I've already said it if you
have a neural network and it has a bunch
of layers and let's draw a couple of
neurons here and the neurons are
connected to each other via connections
connections connections connections and
you have a pruning algorithm now the
prunings algorithms they consider here
or so-called single-shot pruning
algorithms what they do is they look at
the neural network and this can be
before training or after training but
they at some point they look at the
neural network and they each they assign
a score to each of these weights like
daresay your one your a five your a nine
and so on and then they simply prune
away the lowest scores okay and you tell
the network what compression ratio you
want you you tell the network for
example please prune away 90% of the
connections so these algorithms would
look would assign the scores once and
then remove the bottom 90% of weights ok
like this so those are the single-shot
pruning algorithms now what is layer
collapse layer collapse is whenever an
algorithm removes all of one layer
because maybe so here was a nine maybe
you have like 11 12 13 here okay so and
then you're in you're in this situation
right here and the algorithm is pretty
is pretty dumb
it's simply removing the bottom 90% of
the connections and here it figures I
need to remove one more to meet that
goal I remove the one with the lowest
score I'm gonna remove this one and it's
pretty obvious that now no more
information can flow from the beginning
to the end of the network because well
what's where is it gonna flow to its a
bit more complex than that like you can
just retain a layer like a connection
for example if this were a connection
there would also be no information flow
because you'd have no outgoing
connection here but ultimately layer
collapse is whenever an entire layer is
removed okay and they they do say
somewhere that that's the case
I think layer collapse here layer
collapse occurs when an algorithm prunes
all parameters in a single weight layer
even when pruna bill parameters remain
elsewhere in the network so I'm not as
such I'm not sure that this is like a
giant problem it gets to be a problem
but it it could be circumvented fairly
easily right by simply saying if you're
about to prune a connection that's
integral to the information flow from
the start to the end don't prune that
connection prune some other connection
right and then you could simply avoid
that and I'd be interested in how that
works out so um but in this case for
purposes of this paper they simply
consider algorithms that assign a score
and then prove in the bottom couple of
percent okay for so we don't want any
like handcrafted rules in here or
something so they look at this quantity
called the max compression the max
compression is a quantity that's
basically the maximum achievable
compression while still avoiding layer
collapse and they say for example for a
network with LA
and parameters the max compression is n
over L which it basically means every
layer only has one parameter remaining
and therefore and if it's the correct
one
therefore information can flow from
start to the end all right so this is
the maximum achievable compression
anything beyond that would automatically
induce layer collapse now anything
before that could induce layer collapse
but there is a way to compress the
network to the same level without
inducing layer collapse and there point
is basically that these other
compression algorithms that they compare
with they always they always induce
layer collapse before they actually have
to because they cut off a connection
that leads to layer collapse before they
like there would be another connection
that they could cut off that would not
lead to layer collapse and of course if
you are layer if you have done a layer
collapse then you accuracy immediately
drops to zero or to random because no
more information flow so they look at
these things here random pruning is
where you simply assign a random score
to each connection magnitude pruning is
what the lottery ticket hypothesis does
but just they look here at a single shot
so you simply look at the magnitude of
the weights and this can be before or
after training I think they do it after
training here which is classically done
you look at the magnitude of the weight
and you prune the bottom 90 percent away
they there are also two more advanced
methods this s and IP and the grass
piece of snip and grasp which look at
the gradient of the training loss in the
network and they decide according to
that gradient which which things to cut
in which things not to cut away the
grasp even involves the the hessian
right here and so they're fairly you
know complex method that have some
thoughts behind them about why they do
what they do yet they all induce layer
collapse before they actually have to so
they define this thing here
the critical compression the critic the
critical compression is the maximum
compression ratio a given algorithm can
achieve without inducing layer collapse
so the critical compression here is
basically whenever that algorithm goes
to zero that's the critical compression
that's kind of the farthest you can push
the algorithm without him without sorry
him German speaker without it induced
without it inducing layer collapse okay
so you can see that for these baseline
algorithms the layer collapse occurs way
below the theoretically possible max
compression and we're going to see that
in their algorithm this soon flow that
this max compression is achieved and
it's actually achieved without any of
these handcrafted rules that I mentioned
it is the algorithm by design already
achieves this maximum compression ratio
so they formulate this here as a guiding
principle they formulate is an axiom I
would I would rather say it's like this
kind of a it's kind of a a guiding
principle of building these algorithms
that any algorithm you build should have
so the critical compression ratio of a
pruning algorithm applied to network
should always equal the max compression
of that network
it basically means when you build a
pruning algorithm if you push that
pruning algorithm to its limits it
should not do layer collapse unless it
absolutely needs to okay again
the extent of this problem I don't I
don't know but they do demonstrate that
that they can push their algorithm a
fair bit further now without inducing
layer collapse you already see that
these other algorithms like in this
regime apparently layer collapse hasn't
happened yet because they still have
sizable accuracy but there is still a
you know there is a reasonable
difference here between those and the
syn flow algorithm so I'm not too
convinced yet that layer collapse as
such is the problem because they have a
difference before their layer collapsing
as you can see right here and I have a
feeling that this difference here is due
to
this iterative procedure and not
actually due to the phenomenon of lair
collapse but yeah so if it were only
lair collapse what you'll see is that
they do the same same the same and then
at some point is like boom now I have
lair collapse okay yeah so the lair
collapse story I'm not sure but it's
part of the story so let's let's go with
that the second part which is kind of
disconnected so they establish two
things they established a lair collapse
problem and now they establish the
synaptic salience II which then later
they're going to connect to the lair
collapse so the synaptic salience II
they say is a score is any score metric
that can be expressed as the Hadamard
product of this thing with the
parameters okay so each parameter is
going to be multiplied by the gradient
of some function with respect to that
parameter they say where r is a scalar
loss function of the output of a
feed-forward neural network
parameterised by theta
okay so many of these pruning algorithms
can be formulated in this framework
right here and they're there algorithm
can also be formulated in this framework
so you can see the score that the
algorithm assigns to a weight can be
defined as such and as I said many fall
into this category or are similar to
this especially for example they say
when R is the training loss L so this is
the simplest case you take you put data
through the network and then you take
the training loss of that data and you
sort of back propagate it and now you're
going to prune these connections
according to how big the gradient is if
you say the gradient is very big that
must mean the connection is very
important because there's lots of
information flowing through it so if
it's the training loss L the resulting
synaptic salient symmetric is equivalent
to
the score metric used in skeletonization
one of the first network pruning
algorithms the resulting metrics metric
is also closely related to this right
here that this you can see it's not
exactly the same but it's closely
related to the one used in this snip
baseline and also closely related to
this thing right here used in grasp
where it's not just the gradient it's
actually the gradient multiplied by the
hessian to account for curvature okay so
they're going to investigate this
synaptic salience e in neural networks
they formulate two theorems right here
about the conservation of synaptic
salience II remember synaptic since E is
any score that respects this that is
built like this and he score s the
conservation of synaptic saline see all
synaptic saliency metrics respect to
surprising conservation laws that hold
at any initialization and step in
training so these are not either like in
distribution or something like this with
high probability these things hold at
any point in the neural network first is
the neuron wise conservation of synaptic
salience E for a feed-forward neural
network with homogeneous activation
functions and a homogeneous activation
function is an activation function that
is a can be expressed like this for
example Ray Lewis fall into that
category the sum of the synaptic
saliency for the incoming parameters is
to a hidden neuron is equal to the sum
of the synaptic salience e for the
outgoing parameters from the hidden
neuron so what does it mean is actually
pretty simple if you have a hidden
neuron and you look at all the incoming
weights and you look at their synaptic
salience E which is this s score of each
of these weights like what would the
pruning algorithm assign to that and you
look at the outgoing ones then the sum
of all the incoming ones is going to be
equal to
the sum of all the outgoing ones so
that's pretty interesting and they
extend that to layer two the entire
network so an extension of that network
wise conservation of synaptic salience
II the sum of the synaptic salience e
across any set of parameters that
exactly separates the input neurons from
the output neurons of a feed-forward
neural network with homogeneous
activation functions equals that so it
basically says it remains equal so what
does it mean what does it mean - exactly
separate the input from the output
that's basically the definition of a
layer in a neural network so what
they're saying is that you have a bunch
of layers and if you look at a
particular layer like this one here and
you look at the incoming connections and
you sum up all of their synaptic
salience ease that's going to be equal
to the sum of all the synaptic salience
ease of the outgoing connections of that
layer and it can also apply to like a
group of layers and so on but the
synaptic salience E is conserved in that
way now why is that important and here
is where we make the connection with the
layer was it later drop layer whatever
okay the fact that the fact that these
algorithms tend to drop entire layers
before they have to if you have in your
network layers that are of different
sizes so you have large layers and then
smaller layers and smaller layers what
will happen is that since the synaptic
salience E is conserved the sum is
conserved if you have more connections
in one layer so lots of connections lots
of connections and in the small layers
you don't have as many connections the
sum is equal so that means each
individual one here is much much smaller
so the s is very small for each
individual one here and the s is very
large in there
that means the pruning algorithm is
going to really really kill off this
these connections in the big layers
and it's actually going to kill them off
to a point where it probably is going to
eliminate that layer before it even
prunes many of the connections of the
small layer just because of that
conservation fact and they do
experiments like this I think there's an
experiment up here where I like this one
down here better where they basically
show that you have inverse layer size on
the bottom and you have the average
score that the pruning algorithm assigns
to assigns to any connection now these
as we've seen they're not exactly
assigning the scores of the Saleen see
but they're very close to it thus in
flow algorithm does exactly assign the
Synoptics alien see as the score for the
pruning now we've basically seen that
this leads to a bad result but the
synaptic flow is going to compensate for
that but in essence as you can see as
the layers get so inverse layer size
grows which means that later size
shrinks as the layer size gets smaller
the average score of the connections in
the layer is higher and higher which
basically means that the pruning
algorithm if you just let it go by
itself it's going to kill off the
smaller a sorry the larger layers first
because they have the smaller scores and
you can see that even though the other
algorithms don't conform exactly to that
they conform to this approximately so
these here because their score is
closely related to what the syn flow
does and the magnitude pruning because
mostly because now I'm not sure if
that's at the end of the training at the
beginning of the training if you just
initialize then the score is going to be
proportional to it's going to be
proportional to their magnitude and
their magnitude is determined by the
initialization scheme
and the a tional initialization scheme
is most of the time like modern
initialization schemes compensate for
the fact that you have different number
of incoming and outgoing connections and
therefore they would automatically
assign higher number sorry a higher
initialization constant to layers that
have a lower number of parameters so
even the magnitude pruning will conform
to this now it might be absolutely
reasonable to say that that's also at
the case at the end of training because
most parameters aren't going to move
super much during training so this still
approximately holds as you can see here
of course the random one doesn't it
doesn't do that yet because you prune
randomly you're still absolutely subject
to this layer collapse in fact in the
random one the smallest layers would be
the ones to go away first because that
it's just more probable
okay so we've discovered that if you do
something like salient Z scoring or
something that's correlated to it then
you're going to remove the biggest
layers first and that's a problem
and that's what they say this comp this
fact of this conservation laws and the
single-shot nature of these algorithms
that they only assign scores once and
then they prune away whatever the bottom
such-and-such percent are leads to layer
collapse right that's I think we've
established this now that the
combination of the two things leads to
layer collapse now they make a little
bit of an excursion and they say there
is actually something that doesn't run
into layer collapse and that's iterate
iterative pruning algorithms so they
specifically they look at magnitude
pruning they say magnitude pruning which
remember is also if you do it
single-shot it also runs into layer
collapse magnitude pruning avoids layer
collapse with conservation and iteration
so because it iterates it avoids that
and that's what these lottery ticket
hypothesis paper does it does it
iteratively it removes a couple of
connections then it retrains the network
basically recomputes the magnitudes and
therefore recomputes the scores and then
it prunes again and then it recomputes
and come and prunes again and by
recomputing you can basically these some
of the connections that weren't
important before but just survive the
pruning they can now be like wait I have
now way more responsibility as a
connection and they will shoot up in
importance to avoid being pruned so you
can see if you push your network to a
sorry to a high compression ratio then
if you just do this single-shot pruning
you run into this layer collapse at some
compression ratio you simply crash to
random performance or zero performance
yet if you do multiple iterations you
can see here already two iterations then
it's much longer before you run right
here into layer collapse and if you do
three iterations you do much more now
this the three iterations doesn't mean
you prune more like at this at this
point right here to ten to the one all
of these things prune nine out of every
ten connections it's just the thing that
has three iterations prunes maybe first
three and then again three and then
again three out of the ten whereas the
one iteration would prune all of the
nine at in one go okay and they give a
reason for this they gave they say think
that it's the fact that gradient descent
encourages conservation so they give a
little toy example here they say to
better understand the dynamics of the
iymp algorithm during training a little
smaller we will consider the a
differentiable score
this one so this is not exactly
magnitude pruning but it is very close
right it is squared it's just the square
of the parameter instead of the absolute
value of the parameter
they say it's algorithmically equivalent
to magnitude score consider these scores
throughout training with gradient
descent on a loss function using an
infinitesimal step in this setting the
temporal derivative of the parameters is
equivalent to that and thus the temporal
derivative of the score is this so now
they're going to look at how does the
score evolve when they train the network
and the score evolves exactly as the
negative do this alien see surprisingly
this is a form of synaptic saliency and
thus the neuron wise and lair wise
conservation laws from section 4 apply
in particular this implies that for any
two layers of a simple fully connected
Network then this quantity holds so that
there's this is not new but what it
basically says is that through training
these connections equalize thus a D&C
again so if you have a very big layer
and here a very very small layer and
because it's a big layer these scores
are very much lower right it's just
little s and here it's big s per layer
but then if you prune away and you run
gradient descent on this these scores
will tend to become bigger and in in
this case these weights will tend to
grow in magnitude because you've pruned
away the others they now have more
signal probably flowing to them and more
gradient flowing to them and therefore
they're going to grow in size and
therefore their score is going to be
bigger so the this gradient descent of
this iterative procedure makes makes the
makes the scores better for that so
basically counteracts the layer collapse
so they put all of this together and say
theorem three iterative positive
conservative conservative scoring
achieves maximal critical compression if
a pruning algorithm with global masking
and global masking means that you rank
all of the connections and then prune
from all of the connections
it's the difference to layer wise
masking where you say I want to remove
90% of each layer which sounds like it
would avoid layer collapse but also it
works a lot worse than the global one
the global strategy assigns positive
scores that respect layer wise
conservation and if the algorithm so
respecting layer wise conservation it
basically means you you your score
should be or if your score is a salient
z-score then that's the case and if the
algorithm re-evaluates the scores every
time a parameter is pruned then the
algorithm satisfies the maximal critical
compression axiom okay so that that's
basically saying that if you have any
algorithm that prunes with a salient
z-score like theirs is gonna do is going
to to be able to be pushed to the limit
until the maximal capacity is reached if
you re-evaluate the scores every time
parameter is pruned so this is basically
saying that whatever the lottery ticket
hypothesis paper did with magnitude
pruning if you do it with salience e
based pruning you guaranteed to achieve
the maximum possible compression if you
if you push it but of course we know
that whatever the whatever the lottery
ticket hypothesis paper did is
impractical because it needs to retrain
the network every single time it wants
to prune right so if you want to do this
after every parameter that's going to be
a long time it's going to be impractical
we ideally want to prune the
before we even look at any data and
they're going to do exactly that with
the sin flow algorithm they say theorem
3 directly motivates the design of our
novel pruning algorithm syn flow that
provably reaches maximal critical Oh No
ok this was bad
maximal critical compression first the
necessity for iterative sorry first the
necessity for a treat if score
evaluation discourages algorithms that
involve back propagation on batches of
data and the step motivates the
development of an efficient data
independent scoring procedure second
positivity and conservation motive
motive motives probably motivates the
construction of a loss function that
yields positive synaptic salience e
scores we combine these insights and
introduce a new loss function where the
one is the old one vectors or euralia
data ok so this is the loss function of
their salience ease scores and this
might seem like so what what do we have
we have the parameters of layer L the
absolute product a sorry the absolute
value of those parameters and then you
simply multiply all of the layers
together and you have this product here
with the ones on the side so this is a
quadratic form sort of ok this might
seem a bit weird but but in practice and
this is also what happens in their code
you do you can do something pretty easy
so first you have to transform all your
weights to their absolute values now in
their code you can look at it they they
do remember the signs for later so but
first you convert all of them to their
absolute values then second you simply
take a data point that is filled with
ones that literally the number one so if
your if your input is an image you just
put a one at each pixel you feed it
through the network with all of these
positive weights and you get out some
output you get some output vector ok
then you simply you need to do this
inner product with the one vector which
is simply a sum right I don't I don't
get why they it's a bit of a funky way
of writing a sum right you simply sum
that up to get a to get a single number
and this single number now is your is
your pseudo loss function it's simply
the loss function that an all one data
point gets when the when the loss
function is just the sum of the outputs
that's that's the that's it and then you
back propagate that loss to you back
propagate that loss to the layers right
so this is or remember this is not the
score itself but our score is going to
be the derivative of R with respect to a
weight times that weight okay so you
want to back propagate and then you
multiply each of these weights by the
back propagated signal and that's going
to be your score for each parameter now
this doesn't seem too hard right you
some you just need you don't even need a
batch you need a single data point one
back propagation and then you get your
scores okay you don't need expensive
training or anything like this
this seems pretty cool and they give an
example here for example for a simple
come on
for a simple fully connected Network ie
this so they consider here a a linear
network right just so we can look at
exactly what happens for linear networks
you can often compute quantities exactly
so if we look at just a linear network
without nonlinearities we can factor the
synaptic flow score for any parameter as
such so the score this is now not the or
this is going to be the score is going
to be this thing right here so you can
see that the parameter is multiplied by
this thing and by this thing and other
than for example magnitude pruning this
actually takes into
account all the input flow because it
goes from this one sorry it goes from
this goes from this one it goes through
all the network right
every path that arrives at this
particular weight is going to be
considered and every path that goes out
from this particular weight is going to
be considered and the Saleen z-score is
going to depend on all of these paths
all of these all of the information flow
from input to output that goes through
that weight and if you do this then you
get a really good pruning algorithm so
yeah the the algorithm is is I've
already described it and in their
experiments as you can see right now
they have a bunch of networks these VG
networks or like wide ResNet they have a
bunch of data sets like tiny image net
or C 410 where they experiment with
these different baselines and you can
see that the baselines often run into
this layer collapse problem sorry I
often run into this where all of a
sudden let's actually look at let's look
at this resin at 18 right here maybe you
can find a connection between maybe
there is differently sized layers in
resin at 18 and that's why the collapse
happens even earlier but you can see
right here there's a collapse if you do
magnitude pruning even also if you do
random pruning it falls down pretty hard
after a while the baselines they hold up
better but you can see in different
models and different data sets that the
baselines crash at some point as well
now I've already said the comparison
here it seems a little bit unfair I
might I might have over read something
but I'm pretty sure that the baselines
remain single shot while the sin flow
algorithm here is now of course no
longer a single shot it's actually multi
shot and they've made the exact argument
that the single shot is the problem and
therefore their algorithm is Multi multi
shot and it it seems like they should
give the other algorithms the up
opportunity to also do multi-shot just
to compare them fairly me as I said
maybe they're doing that but I'm I
haven't read any anything so it you know
it just seems like the comparison is a
bit unfair if you identify the problem
and then just leave the other algorithms
with the problem same flow is still
different from these other algorithms
even if they had the multiple steps now
the counter-argument to this of course
is that these other algorithms all
require the training data they require
actually passing the data or training
the network in the case of magnitude
pruning and so on so that's pretty
expensive whereas sinfull you simply
pass forward one data point and that's
it that's a good argument but it seems
like the the effect of the synaptic
salience he scores and the effect of the
multiple steps aren't really
disentangled in these experiments right
here it simply shows that it
consistently outperforms other pruning
methods and what what I'd like to see is
really where that outperforming comes
from ok so that's what I think of this
and that was the paper basically I'm
even even if I am not convinced quite
yet
this is pretty cool right and I think
this will if not be even if it's not
used itself it will inspire kind of a a
line of work into pruning at the
beginning of training without looking at
data and maybe you know maybe we can
even think of building networks like
instead of just pruning them we can
think of constructively building
networks that observe these properties
and therefore we can just construct
initialize networks already with good
properties such that we don't even have
to go to a bigger Network and then prune
it down it seems wasteful it seems like
we should just be able to derive
principles of what we want in the
how the weights are structured and then
construct networks that are according to
that and I guess that's what's going to
happen in a few papers that are coming
all right again if you like this video
consider subscribing giving it a like
commenting and let me know what you
think and until next time bye bye